all right I'm fully slurped and I'm
ready to kill stop hi guys I'm Nick and
I'm Nico and today we're going to be
playing fortnight but without weapons I
don't know how we're gonna do it but
there's this challenge on YouTube you
try to make it to the end of fortnight
without weapons if you haven't already
heard a fortnight it's basically a co-op
survival game similar to like The Hunger
Games type of premise words kill or be
killed and you're supposed to be the
last one standing out of a group of a
hundred people you have so many things
to worry about aside from other people
trying to kill you the storm is also
trying to kill you I have a plan I plan
to use either be a bush or build a lot
either - there are many zones on the map
that are spicy meaning a lot of people
drop there at once so you're gonna die
real quick so you try and avoid the
spice before you get spiced you're going
for a snake island even though it's not
an island it just it is connected to the
mainland yeah opposite of an island
whose your fortnight crushed mine is
either Halle Berry look away that's the
one I don't know how your dance moves
are gonna help you when it comes to
hand-to-hand combat I'm just trying to
figure out how to crouch right
- I feel like getting spicy soon so far
doing the 20 already
I am fully clenched right now yeah also
feel like I'm being watched right now
why do you feel like you're being walk
and just feel it but God just get ah oh
there's a guy right there I see him oh
my god don't you come over here please
oh my god no
I'm running the salty springs get away
from me Oh God
thank you please 21st my usual strategy
is to go to moisty Meier that's my
favorite spot I always drop at moisty
Meier what I'll do is I'll probably try
to go like to the very end of the map
without which I was like over here kind
of watch out for people look at
something over there I think nope it's
the stairs nevermind I call this the
crab strategy I'm gonna go ahead and as
if this was plan I'm gonna go ahead and
hang out by the crab I know there's a
giant llama somewhere 16 people left
alright we're doing we're doing really
well I'm not gonna hide no I want to run
you do you see someone I don't know oh
no it's just a speck on my screen just
kidding hopefully nothing happens now I
think we're good I don't know what
happens to be fall down there I was
admiring the view at the at the edge at
the edge of the world and I didn't I
didn't pay attention to the time yeah
this isn't good I think I might die here
that time it was like nearly perfect oh
[Music]
six baby six I'm pretty happy with that
no you can't drop it too soon now you
can drop drop I don't know where to go
I'm gonna go with my gut you just
believe with me you know where to buy
walk girl just so scary it feels like
I'm in a scary movie I'm just gonna sit
here okay I don't want to talk to
anybody I want everybody look at me you
really picked up me words I hate myself
I'm gonna get merged with my butt right
now
no 11 seconds till the circle closes
everyone shut the hell up right now
there may be out of your gonna I don't
know man I even know it's gonna happen
to you
how you surviving the storm comes
I please 37
get back here Howie Barry go back to
Cloud Atlas where you belong